la reunión con el papá francisco fue a
puerta cerrada el pontífice escuchó a
tres representantes de los pueblos
indígenas quienes contaron lo que
vivieron en las escuelas residenciales
dirigidas por la iglesia católica en
canadá en la visita pidieron que el
vaticano reconozca se disculpe y se
responsabilice por los crímenes
cometidos en contra de miles de niños
durante más de 165 años
una disculpa genuina y sincera sería un
primer paso para empezar a sanar estar
wang qing star healing esta es la
primera de cuatro reuniones que se
realizarán a lo largo de la semana en
donde se presentarán 39 testimonios de
violaciones y abusos los representantes
indígenas exigen acciones legales y
acceso sin restricciones a los registros
de las instituciones
si hay acusaciones de que alguien ha
cometido estos abusos deben ser llevados
ante la justicia y la iglesia no debe
interponerse en el camino sino ayudar a
quienes han sido víctimas a buscar
justicia y sanación
y aproximadamente 150.000 niños fueron
sacados de sus hogares y sometidos al
sistema de educación de las escuelas
residenciales católicas la comisión de
la verdad y reconciliación instaurada
para investigar los crímenes calificó lo
ocurrido como un genocidio cultural
nuestros niños llegaron a casa odiando
quienes eran odiando su idioma su
cultura y su tradición más de 4.000
niños murieron mientras asistían a las
140 escuelas de este tipo que existían
en canadá la comisión de la verdad
estima que la cifra real supera los 6000
por lo que continúa en la búsqueda de
restos humanos en los alrededores de las
instituciones